la presidenta de Taiwán concluye este
lunes una visita oficial por
Centroamérica con un día ajetreado en
Belice en donde asistió a la cita más
importante que era la presentación de su
discurso frente a la asamblea nacional
de Belmopán en sus declaraciones la
mandataria sáez subrayó que el pueblo de
Taiwán enfrenta una amenaza constante
por parte de su vecino frente al
estrecho de Taiwán en Clara referencia a
la china que lideran una china que
acumula provocaciones sobre todo con el
anuncio de hoy de la reunión oficial que
sostendrá la presidentai con el
presidente de la cámara de
representantes de los Estados Unidos
Kevin mccarthy y con otros miembros del
Congreso programada para este miércoles
5 de abril esto en la escala que hará la
mandataria y su delegación en California
luego del viaje por Centroamérica y de
regreso a la isla de Taiwán por su parte
el Primer Ministro John briceño reiteró
el reconocimiento a Taiwán como un
estado el verano le agradeció por la
inversión económica sobre todo por una
subvención de más de 16 millones de
dólares para la construcción de un
hospital en el Callo de uno de los
puntos turísticos más importantes de
Belice donde no hay atención
hospitalaria Y esto es un caso
particular porque justamente la
presidentai viene de visitar aquí en
Guatemala el hospital de Chimaltenango
cuya construcción se logró por la
inversión taiwanesa de más de 22
millones de dólares pero que ahora está
envuelto en un caso de corrupción por el
cual el viceministro de salud está
encarcelado Fue capturado el
viceministro de salud del gobierno de
Alejandro yamatei